>>Sundar Pichai: Talking to Terry, it's been
very obvious this passion for the quality
of what they want to see, and they would not
do it on the Web unless they can create an
immersive experience like that.
So it's really possible to do this in the
browser, using HTML5. And we really hope you
and everyone watching this build showcase
applications like what we just saw.
So what does it mean to build on the Chrome
Web Store?
It means that you can reach over 70 million
users. These are primary users of Chrome as
of today.
And in June of last year when we talked about
Chrome OS, we said we had 30 million years.
As of today, we have over 70 million users
and the number is growing fast. These people
will be able to have the Web Store right on
their New Tab page and discover both free
and paid applications.
So it's also important to remember that this
Web Store will also be there in Chrome OS
as well. So the Chrome Web Store will work
on Chrome on Windows, Mac, Linux, and Chrome
OS. It will support both free and paid applications.
It will work in over 40 languages and over
70 countries.
We will be bringing this in the Chrome dev
channel soon and we will have a whole session
at I/O to talk about this.
One thing I want to add is we support standard
Web technologies, and so applications written
for Chrome Web Store will also continue to
work on every other modern browser out there.
So it's been really exciting to talk about
HTML5. We have always believed that the future
of Web is HTML5. And over the course of the
last few months, it's been very exciting to
see every major browser vendor share that
opinion as well.
So with that, I am going to invite Lars Rasmussen,
who spoke to you last year about Google Wave,
an amazing example of what's possible in the
browser, to give a future update on HTML5.
[ Applause ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: Good morning.
Good morning, everyone.
So, the Web has grown up.
And Google Wave is starting to grow up as
well.
It's been a full year since we showed you
what was really our vision for hour real-time
communication and collaboration could work
on the Web.
We showed you right here on this stage with
an 80-minute demo last year.
And today, Google Wave is a product that people
are starting to use to get real work done
all over the world.
And we're going to show you that today with
a 90-minute -- I'm just kidding.
We're not going to do that.
[ Laughter ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: What we are going to do
is this: We're going to open up Wave to everyone
today.
So you no longer need an invitation to use
Wave.
Just go to Wave.google.com and log right in.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: Thank you.
So we're making -- we're making Wave part
of Google Apps, where particularly ambitious,
you might even say crazy services start their
life.
Maps, my last project, started there five
years ago.
Wave has been in an invitation-only preview
for half a year.
We've gotten tons of great feedback.
Thanks so much for that.
And more than anything, we've learned that
Wave really shines as a place to get work
done, in particular, if you have a group or
a team of people that use Wave to collaborate
on all manners of projects.
And the thing we hear a lot -- and this actually
matches our own experience -- is that Wave
changes the way you work, sometimes in subtle
and unexpected ways.
And we hear this in many different contexts.
Of course, lots of programmers use Wave to
coordinate their work.
But we hear things like a fifth-grade teacher
has her students do all the research in Wave.
And the kids love the live typing.
It feels like you're talking to the other
participants on the Wave.
And the teacher loves it because she can see
in real time what they're doing and jump right
in and provide guidance.
Brick-and-mortar businesses like this hotel
here, they use Wave exclusively to track and
discuss all of their tasks during the day.
They tell us how Wave stops issues from falling
through the cracks and helps keep everyone
on the same page every day.
Deloitte is a good example.
They have a new project team that's spread
over four or five countries.
And they use Wave to coordinate all of the
work and tell us how Wave actually saves them
money in travel and VC cost.
And so since Wave is about getting work done,
it's important for us to get Wave -- make
Wave available at work and at schools.
So also today, we're making Wave part of Google
Apps.
If you have an apps domain, you or your administrator
can easily enable Wave for all of your users
at no extra cost.
[ Applause ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: Thank you.
And let me just say this: If you tried Wave
already, in particular, early on during the
preview, and you found it wasn't quite ready
to get work done, now's a good time to come
back and give it a second try.
Wave is a lot faster and it's a lot more stable
than when we started the preview.
We put a lot of work into the basic preview
things.
You can now get e-mail notifications when
-- we have found it easier to navigate the
unmet pieces of the Wave.
We have added tutorials and templates to help
new users get started.
You can have -- remove a participant if you
add them by mistake.
If you have a group or team and you're working
on a project together, try out Wave.
I think you will find it makes you more productive.
Now, this is a developer event.
And I think already some of the coolest things
about Wave are things you guys are built.
We really, really appreciate that.
And continuing to improve our APIs are hugely
important to us.
Just a few months ago, we launched an entire
new version of our robot API that lets robots
create waves and push content into waves on
their own schedule.
We also made it a lot easier to embed a wave
on your own Web site.
We even made it possible for a non-Wave user
to see a public wave that you embedded on
your Web site.
Today, we're checking off a bunch of top-requested
features or APIs.
For starters, we're rolling out a change that
means that robots no longer have to live on
Google App Engine.
They can live anywhere on the Web, which makes
it a lot easier to integrate Wave with your
own application.
We're also launching a new Wave data API designed
to let you build things like notifiers, but
also lightweight clients, in particular, for
mobile devices.
We're adding media and attachment features
to both our robot and gadget APIs so you can
integrate with places like Picasa and Flickr
and so on and build inline viewers for media
types in Wave.
We're also adding a bunch more hooks for your
extensions to integrate into our client.
And if you want to see some of the cool things
people have already built, join us out on
the floor in the developer sandbox.
For example, Salesforce.Com is with us today,
showing how they're embedding waves into their
new product, Chatter.
Also, we've always wanted Wave to be an open
technology so that anyone should be able to
build their own Wave service and have it interoperate
in real time with Google Wave.
And so we were super excited late last year
when Novell announced their new product, Pulse
is going to support the Wave Federation protocol.
And today, SAP is announcing that their new
product, StreamWork, will also support the
Wave Federation protocol.
Both companies are with us today, out on the
floor and at a session later, where we'll
show demos of how our different Wave services
are starting to be able to talk to each other
in real time.
And to make this sort of thing easier for
others to build their own Wave systems, we
are today open-sourcing additional components
of our production code, in particular, the
in-browser editor, which is one of the hardest
pieces to write.
We're also publishing --
[ Applause ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: Thank you.
We're also publishing -- and this is another
top-requested feature -- we're publishing
the beginnings of a client/server protocol
so that you guys will be able to build any
Wave client you want and put it on top of
any Wave services that speaks this new protocol,
which, of course, will include Google Wave.
Now, just to end off, I want to remind you
that we're using Wave at this conference here.
There's a couple of waves allocated for each
session.
You can use them to ask questions of the presenter.
Someone will take live notes, and you can
discuss the session in there.
I really hope to see you later, either out
on the floor, at one of the many sessions
that we have today and tomorrow, or, of course,
on Wave.
Happy Waving, everyone.
[ Applause ]
>>Lars Rasmussen: Thank you.
And so just like Wave is getting to work,
our next speaker will talk about the Web going
to work.
Please welcome Google director of engineering,
David Glazer.
[ Applause ]
>>David Glazer: All right, all right.
>>David Glazer: So Sundar showed you how open
standards are leading to innovation in the
consumer Web, with the help of people like
Terry and Kevin and Hakon, showed you how
open standards have always allowed more choice,
which has always led to more innovation.
Lars showed you how that's true with Google
Wave.
And he showed you how Google Wave is now heading
off to work.
Well, I'm going to spend the next 45 minutes
showing you more about how is the Web making
work better, what are the things that we can
do to help the Web transform what we all do
at work, what our customers do at work, what
our partners do at work, how can the Web help
there.
The good news is, the Web is already transforming
the way we work.